you ever just run out of apps on Inferno
and just gotten absolutely destroyed
thanks to this recent change that valve
just made that's not going to happen and
I'm going to show you why one of the
biggest changes to Inferno and CS2 is
that you can now Molly pit which is one
of the biggest best power positions in
the game from apps all you're going to
do is walk in the center between this
pillar and this railing thing right here
and then you see this sort of Barb Wire
you're just going to simple left click
what this does is let you Molly pit from
apps without exposing yourself to the
rest of the bomb site from the exact
same spot you're going to left and right
click at the same barb wire a smoke what
this is is going to be a lur smoke that
allows te's to pop safely out of apps
down into pit so from the same spot
you're going to crouch you're going to
aim right basically just at the top of
this white thing right here first flash
second flash altogether this is going to
give you a nice aggressive concealed hul
pop that's actually going to make taking
a site way way easier for the te happy
frag